so I just got back from the Snowman
cinematic trainwreck
cinematic trainwreck 2017 the Snowman
this one is definitely a candidate for a
future art of editing video it's I don't
want to say I don't know where to start
because I do know where to start with
this one
so so this is an incomplete movie that's
sort of the first thing to say about it
it is incomplete I already know that
they didn't finish making the movie and
it shows like it it shows dramatically
they were only able to shoot from what
from what they've said they you know
they're obviously they're gonna try to
downplay it when you end up in a
situation like that so the the director
is trying to play it as it's like oh
well you know 10 15 percent I'm gonna
say they they probably failed to shoot
about 20 percent or 20 percent of the
movie maybe like 10 percent of the
script but definitely like 20 percent of
the planned shots did not get shot and
so that's kind of the baseline that
we're starting from here is that there
we have a clear story for why the
editing is so awful and it is because
the movie isn't done it it shows like
there are sections of the movie that are
better than others that work better than
others but for the most part it's just
it it is chaos just from looking at it
I'm gonna guess that the the reason why
it's incomplete almost entirely comes
down to mismanagement like just the
there's something about the composition
of it that really says that it was not
well planned it wasn't just like it
wasn't well executed and it wasn't well
executed because it wasn't properly
planned there's there's this one scene
very early on that's just a it's just a
back and forth it's like you know shot
reverse shot but each each of the shots
is on a slider but every line that a
character
says starts from the same point in the
move so it's if you've got this pillar
in the background that you're using is
kind of a landmark reference point you
know every time it cuts back to
character a Atlas at the head of the
line at the head of that line the pillar
is back in the same place every single
time it cuts back so it kind of you know
it it tells me that what they were doing
on set is is they were faffing about
constantly resetting and basically
shooting the movie like lion byline like
that scene would have taken forever to
shoot that way and it looks awful it
cuts terribly because it's doing it for
both sides of this so it's like this
once you know it goes mmm every single
time and the other shot goes the other
direction and both of them so it's you
know there's probably 1015 cuts in this
conversation as a whole because it just
cuts on you know character says align
finish character line line line line it
just cuts back and forth like that and
because it's doing this every single
time it forms this really really stupid
rhythm that does not look good it
doesn't feel good it doesn't serve
anything but it would have taken forever
to shoot and there's a lot of other big
scenes like they spend a lot of time on
a techno crane they spend a lot of time
on a dolly they spend like every shot is
not every shot but like there there's a
lot of movements that would have taken a
long time to set up so they knew that
they had a limited schedule that they
had to move very fast on this shoot that
they only had I think it was a pretty
compressed shoot I want to say it was
something like 30 shoot days I would
need to I would need to check that but
it was a it was a very compressed shoot
that they they had and they had no
wiggle room for for going over and
knowing that they still chose to try to
shoot every single scene in
in a complex way and the problem there
is that it's going to take so much time
and particularly like after the first
couple of days if you're not making your
day if you're not getting everything
that you need in the day then you need
to change the way that you're
approaching it you can't just keep going
you're gonna slip farther and farther
and farther behind and then you're not
going to have a finished movie at the
end and that's the situation that they
wound up and they didn't have a finished
movie because they you know they weren't
making their days and so even the scenes
that are done you know don't feel
complete like they feel like they're
they're missing coverage they're missing
endings they're they're missing dialogue
like there are numerous numerous moments
in this movie where scenes have
basically been created out of b-roll so
there's a where you know there's a
misdirect and and the characters are
driving away from a crime scene and then
they've got to turn around and go back
because they get a call you know
and that moment doesn't hat like it
doesn't take us inside the car at all we
don't actually see the characters it's
just a shot of a car driving down the
highway and the two characters talking
overtop of it and the best part is that
when they say they've got to turn around
like the car doesn't turn around they
didn't have a shot of the car turning
around they just had a shot of a car
driving down the highway and so they
used that and then put voiceover overtop
of it to try to create this to try to
create this scene and now having that is
better than nothing but then there's so
many scenes where they just have nothing
there's a lot of jump cuts there's a lot
of oh oh just really really not not well
padded scenes
the entire intro which is supposed to be
like the the killer's backstory like you
know their formative moment it moves at
such a choppy pace that there there is
no there's no setup there's no suspense
there's no sense of what characters are
thinking it's just there's a couple
shots where like clearly you know
there's a there's a stunt that clearly
they only got one of and it wasn't a
very good take but it's all they had so
they have to cut like really early into
the action and you it ends up not it
ends up feeling incomplete alright quick
quick kind of plot synopsis so the
Snowman is a suspense thriller murder
mystery movie about Harry Hole now I
don't know this is this is apparently
based off of a very popular book series
you know long-running long-running book
series that I am completely unfamiliar
with I'm not familiar with the source
material at all I can't comment on it
the best I know is that it's kind of a
you know airport reading type book like
really you know newsstand kind of pulpy
suspense novels you know and I I don't
know if it adheres to it at all but it
very clearly wants you to kind of
already know something about these
characters or have some investment in
the main character named Harry hole
which saying it out loud is is is
chronically absurd the movie is itself
is absurd in in a lot of ways but it
takes itself deadly serious
it probably could have used a little bit
of levity given that it's really kind of
a nonsense
of mystery like you're you're talking
about a serial killer who who builds
snowmen as his calling card and yeah
it's it's not very satisfying on the
whole the the the killer is revealed
ended I don't want to say it makes sense
because it's dumb it's one of these
movies where they didn't actually have a
well-constructed mystery and so they end
up just throwing like tons and tons of
misdirects at you so one of those movies
were about like about two-thirds of the
way through you would believe anyone is
the killer because they have tried to
implicate basically everyone but none of
them would make any sense at all because
the killer just doesn't make sense in
the first place
so it's like oh well it could they they
could turn out to be any of these
characters but which one's it going to
be like there isn't actually one that
that really makes you go like oh man
yeah it all makes sense now cuz none of
them makes sense
none of them it's it's the kind of
killer who has who has super powers you
know can can just get in and out of
places completely invisibly can you know
lock rooms from the inside and and
escape without leaving any trace and
none of its ever explained at all and so
it's the kind spend so much time kind of
mired in a you know dull droning kind of
reality really undercuts all of that
because it's like your tone is so you
know everybody talking in kind of these
these you know low whispers about like
okay well we're gonna what we're gonna
do we're gonna we're gonna have to we're
gonna have to find him
and we're gonna stop on it's the last
thing we do you know it's that kind of a
that kind of a movie but you have this
really absurd premise and a lot of
really absurd things
is going on that definitely could have
been glossed over a lot better if the
movie just felt a little bit more
fanciful if it felt a little bit more
fantastic so it's not a it's not a good
mix of tone and scope the the ending
just because this is fresh on my mind
the ending like the final the final
moments the like the last like three
minutes of the movie are hilarious in
how incomplete they are the the killer
is stopped and that's almost it like
basically Harry goes and rescue like so
The Killers stopped
Harry goes and rescues the hostages and
there's there's no wrap-up of really any
kind it just cuts to this really weird
sets where there's a whole bunch of
people sitting in like you know those
those chairs that have the have the pull
up desks so they're they're sitting in
those but they're just kind of scattered
haphazardly around the room like there's
there's no order to it it's not like
there ain't you know they're not in a
semicircle they're not in lines or rows
they're just all pointed random
directions and it's not clear what's
going on and then you know camera kind
of weaves through it and someone's
talking like droning overtop of this and
it's really hard to hear them because
it's it's like that you know it's that
voice processing effect that they do
when it's like you know someone got hit
in the head and everything sounds super
distant and quiet you know it's like the
audio is really far away and so you got
this kind of just like droning voice off
in the distance and then you know
reveals Harry and he puts up his hand
and says I'll take it and it's supposed
to be sequel bait it's supposed to be
like it wasn't until after that so Harry
says I'll take it and then hard cut to
to black and a roll credits and that's
supposed to be you know setting up like
oh he's he's gonna tackle more cases in
the future
but because because what was being said
was so dulled out you weren't really
processing yet and you're you're
wandering through this room that is it
makes no sense it's like wait where are
we what's going on like this does not so
I pieced it together as the credits were
rolling that it's like oh wait that's
supposed to be like the briefing room
and they're the the that was you know
whoever's in charge like reading out the
details of a case for the detectives to
decide to take but it it didn't it
didn't look like that at all it it
looked like some classroom just it I
don't know
Val Kilmer is in this and this is a
little bit this is a little bit tragic
so I know that Val Kilmer has he I
understand that he has had some health
problems recently I don't know the
details of it but it has impacted his
his mouth and face and throat in in some
way and you can see it like that his his
cheeks are very very swollen he's having
trouble like moving his lips and it's I
understand that maybe his enunciation is
probably not the best of these days I
think they still should have rolled with
it like if if he was able to deliver
anything resembling a good performance
they should have just kept it they
should have used his performance because
what they decided to do instead was they
they dub over him all the way through so
how they try to deal with it at first
for the first scene that he's in he has
about five lines and four of them are
off-camera so it'll do you know standard
shot reverse shot but like over the
shoulder reverse shot but all of his
lines are looking like
all of his characters lines are looking
at the other character like it's the
back of his head and it becomes so
obvious afterwards like what they're
doing when you know it's the fourth time
that they've done it and everything else
is cut normally but it's like when it
comes time for his for his lines back of
his head you're looking at the back of
his head and then they've got one line
where he's on camera and it it really
does not match up at all and they use
that technique like a lot through the a
lot through the movie like they find
basically as many excuses as they can to
have him not be on camera when he's
talking and when he is on camera it the
the the voice does not match up with the
mouth you know he clearly sounds like
someone who's gonna who's gonna have
kind of a a really rough voice like this
is this is what you would expect them to
sound like something closer to this and
they should have just rolled with it
they should have they should have let it
be because even if it would have been
maybe a little weird on its own it would
have at least looked right and it would
have cut better and they would have been
able to do more with the scenes and it
would look it would just be less weird
it would be a lot less weird what do we
have
Oh Harry just wanders around and stares
at people for the first 10 minutes yeah
so after the after the killers backstory
we're introduced to Harry by which I
mean we're not introduced to him at all
it's just a really poorly cut montage of
him like walking up to windows and
looking at people and yeah that's that
strange really strange product placement
they so beats by dre pays a pretty
decent amount to be placed in basically
any movie that will take their money and
so there's a really really
weird product placement where Harry
travels all the way up to to like
northern Norway and goes to like a fish
packing plant and randomly the dude that
he's talking to is sitting there wearing
beats by dre headphones in this fish
packing plant it is it is a really
really mismatched bit of set dressing of
costuming but hey you got to get your
product placement dollar somewhere I
guess they couldn't decide what to do
with the title back to the beginning of
the movie it this really threw me off is
that there's all of these moments where
so like a car drives into into a tunnel
and it smashes to black and then holds
black for a good like two seconds
and then later on there's a scene where
it's like something happens and the
camera pans up and it's just looking out
over over this frozen lake and the
mountains and holds there for a couple
seconds and then a few seconds after
like after that it cuts to black and
holds there for a few seconds and then
goes into the next scene and it's like
so there's like these three moments
where it was like clearly kind of
planned at some point this like oh well
you know here's where we're gonna put
the titles that it's like okay camera
pans up over this gorgeous this gorgeous
frozen lake and you're expecting the
snow man to to come up on screen or when
the car drives into the tunnel or when
it goes to black after that but then
it's like a few beats after all of these
moments that then it just kind of comes
up in like the bottom left corner as as
Harry's like waking up on a bench and
yeah yeah so there's there's more
it's not very good a lot of people are
gonna ask like okay well how does it
compare to to book of Henry and it
really doesn't in in a lot of ways like
book of Henry is a very different kind
of bad and chaotic sort of sort of
filmmaking it's it's it's also it's a
completely different kind of bad versus
Suicide Squad suicide squads problem was
that they had way too much footage that
they had you know the they just overshot
because they over wrote everything and
then they needed to try to trim it down
into him into a presentable package this
is the opposite problem they had a story
that you know I don't know I I honestly
just looking at it like the script was
probably not super great to begin with
but it was probably a lot you know
better than the the final product makes
it look so they probably had they had a
middle in quality murder-mystery script
and and they didn't finish shooting it
you know they they got eighty percent of
what they needed and then just tried to
cut around all of the holes and cut
around the lack of coverage and cut
around the bad takes and and I mean I I
still think it would have been pretty
middling otherwise like there are
definitely some script problems and
there were definitely problems in how
they approached shooting even the parts
of the script that they had like I more
footage was not going to make up for the
fact that like the characters never talk
to each other about the case that
they're working on like that there there
are scenes where you know the
conversation starts and then someone
just gets like really angry and and
walks away and it's like you're you're
like what what do you you know so story
wise there's there
we're definitely I think some core some
core issues there that were certainly
not improved by a lack of footage so
yeah I I would say expect a art of
editing and the snowman sometime in the
future